-And I'm sorry
about that stumble.
Let me explain.
-Did you stumble?
-I did.
I staggered a little bit.
It is not alcohol.
I'm...
[ Audience laughs ]
-Some doubt!
Some doubt from the audience!
-Let's just talk
between ourselves.
I have vertigo.
-Forever?
-Even on your studio set.
I've had it about five months,
and it is diminishing.
I am told it will go away
in time.
That explains
my little tottering there
for a moment.
It was not alcohol!
[ Audience laughs ]
-Well, thank you
for fighting through that
and being here, because this is
very exciting.
-Nobody else I would do it for.
-Well, I appreciate it.
Although, I'm pretty sure
I've seen you on talk shows
all week long.
[ Audience laughs ]
-Found out!
Darn!
-Still, I mean, Patrick,
you have a long,
you have an illustrious career.
Royal Shakespeare Company
for ten years.
-Yeah!
-But here you are,
the Poop Emoji.
Was this...
-I know, I know.
-Was it all --
Do you feel like
it was all heading for this?
-Do that again!
-Was it all heading for this?
-Isn't that wonderful?
Um..
-If you play that
in reverse, it's...
[ Laughter ]
-I always knew that there was
something waiting for me.
-Right.
[ Audience laughs ]
-It's very hard
to talk seriously about
this role, you know.
-Yeah.
-But this must --
I mean, again, of the Emojis,
this must've been
a coveted role.
I would feel like many actors
would've said yes right away
to the Poop Emoji.
Did you have to fight for this
of the Emojis?
-Fight other actors?
-Yeah!
-Yeah, no, no.
[ Audience laughs ]
Um, it came to me,
and it came in an e-mail.
And it was the quickest response
I have ever given to any...
-You jumped for it.
-Jumped all over it!
Yes, exclamation mark,
exclamation mark.
-Well, I think it's a gift,
because now I will never be able
to separate the Poop Emoji
from your voice.
[ Audience laughs ]
And that will give it
a great dignity.
-Is that going to be
a problem for you, Seth?
-I don't know, I don't.
I think it'll make be --
It'll make my life better.
What happened there?
-Excuse me, I don't know.
I've got threads hanging out
of my shirt, you know?
-Believe it or not...
-I've got to stop..
-...I think if
you'd have left it alone,
we wouldn't have noticed.
[ Audience laughs ]
-You know, I am a great fan.
We've talked about
your early work as well
when you've been here
in the past, because even before
"Star Trek," I knew you
from some BBC productions.
And I was looking back,
and I actually found on YouTube
you playing Horatio in "Hamlet."
And this is young
Patrick Stewart.
And, that is just fantastic.
[ Audience cheers ]
-Yeah.
-Now, that's a wig?
[ Audience laughs ]
-Oh, a wig!
Is it a wig!
-Yeah, what did
you think I said?
-[ Laughs ] I thought
you said, "Is it win?"
And I was...
-Is it a win to do Shakespeare?
-It's a hairpiece.
-Oh, it's a hairpiece.
-Yeah, yeah.
There's too little of it
to be a wig.
That's the secret
of wearing false hair.
You wear as little as possible,
then it looks more natural.
-Okay, gotcha.
-You will not have
to worry about that
for a very, very long time.
And this, by the way,
I have to say,
is an actor called
Ian Richardson.
-Ian Richardson's
a fantastic actor.
-Great and brilliant actor.
-Yeah.
Well, we talked about
"Tinker Tailor Soldier Spy"
when you were in it.
He was Bill Haydon in that,
which was one of
the great roles.
-Wonderful performance.
-Yeah, absolutely.